the idea of blood sucking creatures has
been around for quite a while for it is
there in most cultures but what I want
to look at in terms of the vampire is
looking mostly at how it has developed
in the modern time especially from the
time of Bram Stoker it seems like the
vampire has taken up a particular niche
in the world of monsters and I think
it's a niche that it's important to
understand at the moment
[Music]
this is Jonathan pezzo welcome to the
symbolic world
[Music]
now the notion of vampires has been
around for a very long time the idea of
things coming people coming back from
the dead - to take other people's blood
you in the let's say and the older
versions of the vampire it's mostly the
imagery of a parasite or you know of
something which is coming from the
outside which is coming from below you
know like like an insect or a mosquito
that is feeding off the living and so it
is really this parasite a way to
understand it is how let's say on a more
psychological level is to understand
something like someone who dies and what
they left as a legacy is going to
continue to gnaw at you for one reason
or another is going to continue to act
as a parasite on your life despite the
fact that it is that person is gone the
way that the vampire has taken form in
the modern time especially since it
since the time of Bram Stoker a little
bit just with the basic idea of Count
Dracula and the idea of an aristocrat
who becomes this vampire who sells his
soul to the devil or does something
similar and then becomes this creature
of the night and so the interesting
aspect of this vampire is that it really
becomes the image of a monstrous version
of the hierarchy a monstrous version of
the aristocracy and it's not surprising
that it would appear in the time that it
appeared in a moment where narratives
about the aristocracy narratives about
hierarchy themselves were like let's say
revolutionary or were you know you could
see the development of Marxism coming
about the development of you know we had
the French Revolution was already gone
all of these you know the Russian
Revolution all this idea that somehow
aristocrats or anything that is a
hierarchy is bad was setting itself up
so it's not surprising that the image of
the vampire the way it appears to us
would appear around that time but at the
same time I you know of course it shows
some you know a political slant that the
world is taken but nonetheless if you
look at the image it can help us
understand
the danger of hierarchy or the negative
side of the of something which is above
and the way that it shows it is in a
normal relationship between in a normal
hierarchy what is above does in fact
feed on what is below that is of course
something which might disturb you but it
just you know they just happens you you
if you are if you let's say you are an
interpreter and you're building
something you hire a bunch of people and
you're going to feed on their energy in
order to accomplish what you want you
know if you have people under you in the
army or in any business you are feeding
from them their food for your project in
order to accomplish your goal so that in
itself is not necessarily weird what is
dangerous is when the effort only goes
one way because usually what happens is
there's an exchange you the people below
in the hierarchy will offer support will
offer sustenance will be like the food
for the project or the moving towards
the goal that this structure has in mind
and what's coming from above will give
back value will give back identity will
give back in terms of a political sphere
will give back protections that will
come from above and so you know the role
of an aristocrat is of course to protect
here's the people on his land he's
supposed to protect them from invaders
protect them from from anything that
could happen to the land but also even
provide medical help provide often
education basic education to the people
that were working for him and so that is
the normal exchange you can all you can
always see the normal exchange in a
hierarchy as the idea that there's love
coming from above and there's a kind of
submission or a kind of pliable 'no
scumming from below where you submit to
the purpose of this higher thing and the
care comes from above so that is the
normal version but in the idea of the
vampire what you have is you have what
is this
Socratic figure which will seduce but
then will only feed and will not give
back will not produce will only take and
so you can understand it in the of
course in the vision of the
revolutionaries that that's what the
aristocracy was doing was only taking
from below and you can see it in the
Marxist you know idea of what the rich
do is that all they do they feed from
below and they don't give enough back
and so the vampire exemplifies that
becomes a an image of that and it can
help you understand you know even in
your own experience in the way that you
act in the world how you need to be
attentive to the things which are below
and it's not just it you can see it in
yourself as well you can imagine it like
this you can imagine it as you have your
purposes your goals your your intentions
and then you have your possibilities
your body your time your resources and
if you're not careful you can act as a
vampire upon yourself that is you can
suck the life out of yourself you can
work yourself to death you can work
yourself into a kind of zombie state if
you ever seen those old movies of people
that have been bitten by vampires
you know they're kind of wide-eyed and
they're not totally there they're
they're kind of half there half dead
themselves and so you can do that to
yourself where you are taking from your
body and you're not giving back and
everybody has had that experience so you
can understand it because everybody has
at times where they are not sleeping off
they're not eating enough they're not
doing what they need to do in order to
give back to their possibilities but
rather they're just trying to suck
themselves dry and so that is what I
think the vampire today represents and
in a way it's almost as if it's the
opposite of something like the zombie
where in the case of the zombie you have
these monsters coming from below that
are eating the brain you know so you
have the body eating the brain and in
the terms of the vampire you have
something like the brain which is eating
the body you have the top which is
devouring what is underneath and trying
to sustain itself by only taking and
that of course doesn't work in the long
term and you can keep adding to your
body for a while you know you can take
caffeine you can you can take cocaine
you can take cocaine you do all kinds of
things to kind of try to add to your
body in order to be able suck it dry you
can see the same
of the aristocrat or the leader who who
is devouring his people they can add
people they can try to - - just keep
sucking the blood from different people
but at some point that will you know
that will give them a kind of unnatural
long life but at some point it is
inevitable that that will fall apart and
that will break down and so in a way
what it ends up being is if there are
sins of the passions you could call them
and there are sins of sins of the mind
you could call them the vampire seems to
to manifest mostly the sins of the mind
or the sins of of the elite it's pride
really and it's really this idea that I
I am so important that I can suck all
these people dry and it's justified
because of my own self-importance and so
that fits with the idea of the
aristocrat or the idea of a leader which
would be full of himself and would not
see themselves rather as having to care
and to help those that are below them
and one of the that say one of the
interesting aspects which still remains
from the older legends that can help you
understand the the problem that I'm
trying to show you is this idea that
vampires can't stop themselves from
counting there you know these legends
that if you want to get rid of a vampire
you should throw some rice on the ground
or something and then the vampire will
have to count out every single piece of
rice that they can't stop themselves
from doing that and in that image you
can see this idea like the sin of the
mind is sin - through counting through
through through math to be able to
account for everything and so - the sin
of the vampire is is actually not to let
let's say the lower things be but had
has to account for all of them and so in
that manner you could imagine the
vampire as being something like a like a
false light you know something like a
false hierarchy a a mockery of a
hierarchy you know the that is why they
don't have a reflection there kind of
this false light this false
mystic rat and so it's like a dark
hierarchy you could imagine it that way
and so that seems also to be the reason
why the way to get rid of the vampire is
through sunlight through exposing you
know exposing the sins of the of the
Father you could say something like that
to be a to show the evils of the
aristocracy to expose their vices and to
do all that something which we've seen
in history of course quite a bit you
know how people in elite circles tend to
think that they and everything is
permitted to them that they think that
because they are above other people in
terms of social hierarchy that somehow
the rules of the world don't apply to
them and so a way in a way to get rid of
the vampires is of course to shine a
light on them and to show them for what
they truly are and in that sense it's
also the true hierarchy or the true law
which ends up showing itself when you
shine a light on it and that also seems
to make sense in terms of the the basic
idea of the cross why the cross would
also would also frighten them in terms
of this hierarchy of sacrifice that we
find in Christianity which is exactly
the opposite of what they are putting
out there and so the one thing that I'm
not sure about and maybe you guys can
help me out in the comments section is
in my let's say basic idea it seems like
everything is kind of coherent kind of
makes sense but the one thing that I'm
struggling with is garlic why is it
garlic frightens vampires and I'm sure
there's something I'm missing some
aspect of the of garlic the only thing I
can kind of think of is that maybe it
has to do with a kind of purification so
you know garlic as an astringent garlic
as this kind of really pure thing kind
of like light shining on something like
that but here I really feel like I'm
speculating so I'll leave it up to you
guys and hopefully if if you guys if I
you say something that I found
convincing in the comments I will pin
the comment and
and give my own response so I hope you
enjoyed this small little thought on
vampires I'm going to put out at least
one more monster video for patrons only
it's going to be the one on imps and
goblins that one is very wide but I'm
going to focus on one aspect as well
mostly why is it that imps and goblins
all these stories of them working at
night for us and doing things for us at
night
and then in the morning the things are
already done and I've been thinking
about that a lot and I think I have an
interesting idea about that so thanks
everybody for your support and I will
see you soon I wanted to give a quick
shout out to to Murphy's to Murphy's is
a musician who is doing meaning way of
music kind of like a cure the dawn and
some of you have heard the song
obviously Santa Claus exists that he did
from last year so - Murphy's is
contacted me and said he wanted to make
a bunch of songs based on my content and
he put out the first song which is on
extremism and is based on a discussion
that I had about Sam Harris and his
deluded sense of history with a pretty
interesting kind of dark rap beat in the
background as you can hear it playing
right now so I'm gonna put a link to to
his channel in the description to check
them out and
for more songs coming soon it's always
this idea that that we don't have kind
of this secular extremism you know it's
like what are you talking about
even the French Revolution was exactly
that I keep thinking